join the CinemaSins team in Nashville
for sin week 2023 every year we release
extra videos for our sin club members
and hold live panels with our friends
and fans in person tickets to sin week
are available at a discounted rate for
the month of December space is limited
so head to cinemasins.com cineweek to
reserve your spot today the link is in
the description
[Music]
thank you
remember the original Game of Thrones
credits remember how it would fly over
the map to give you a sense of geography
enhance the show you were watching yeah
well this show is like nope we're going
with blood culverts emptying into Metal
Gears because who doesn't like a bit of
pointless and unintelligible
trickle-down necronomics also shows logo
promises a three-headed dragon and I'm
starting to doubt we're ever gonna see
one it's been near six years since I
last saw my Lord husband maester see six
years six years you have arguably the
best ending of the season in the
previous episode and now we're skipping
ahead six years and not getting into
anything that happened right after all
that chaos [ __ ] this show sometimes man
although I think it would actually
probably enjoy that this is like a
strong calling your grandpa the sea
snake and instead of Grandpa he didn't
put all that work into impregnating your
grandmother and then going through nine
months of putting up with her being
pregnant for you to show such disrespect
I am the sea snake unplugged the closest
King he has left be careful good brother
one could take your words for treason or
one could take his words as completely
unimportant since I'm not even sure the
show really knew he existed until now my
cousin the king would have your tongue
tongue shadowing giving us so much
gratuitous Castle porn I half expect the
Downton Abbey theme to start playing
admonishing yourself in the third person
like some sort of 21st century teenager
at this point just have the kid call his
dad's plan's cap and brag about his drip
which I swear is a real thing a king
should honor the traditions of his
forepass thinking that following Yogi
Baloo poo in Fozzie will help you be
king there's only one bear we follow in
these parts and his name starts with a P
an ends in an Addington he means to cool
into question Luke's legitimacy ah goody
another episode revolving around
political chess because this show never
tackles this subject matter enough this
back and forth of who gets to be king
and who gets to be head of this Castle
or that land is enough to lose your head
over or at least half of it
and the valarian nine
but about our politics I don't care
about them either so enough of the
housing can we please move on to the of
the dragoning to King's Landing then
cool we're headed back to Kingsley
ending wouldn't want this show to stop
feeling cramped and insular would we
[Music]
say it's nice to be home but I scarcely
recognize it something I find even less
exciting than political chess matches is
characters complaining about Decor
seriously guys if it doesn't get more
exciting than this I might chop my own
head off at least half of it we'll
continue to enjoy improved customs
duties since the settling of the
stepstones House of the Dragon episode
can't exist without mentioning the
stepstones cliche I trust they've been
welcomed as befits their station as you
instructed Lord hand one thing these
time jumps do is take away any suspense
or dramatic pleasure we might have been
able to get from past actions that we
never saw take place yes we knew the
hand from six years ago was killed but
we never actually saw the scene stealer
from Notting Hill get to take his old
position back considering how much
dramatic weight was given to him having
his position taken away this could have
actually been an interesting development
to see but instead he's already just
back in his seat putting his balls on
the table they can fly a dragon yes but
can he command Fleet a bullet he does
not alter his claim this episode is like
if succession focused all of its energy
on successions that weren't even the
main succession and was also really
boring showing Levy attacks
oh man we're leaving the scene right as
they're getting into some new wool tax
discussion damn it I wanted to hear
about that amata has arisen that
requires your attention whatever it is I
reckon you need to wait America Grace
imagine not having subtitles on him
being like Oh you're Eric not Eric got
it I swear this Eric Eric nonsense
better lead to some first-rate parent
trappinger For the Love of Haley Mills I
will Revolt who goes
no you were Nera he father
[Music]
and by up I mean my reclining Position
will go from approximately 15 degrees to
about 20 degrees but it's really
important that the audience understand
what bad shape I'm in so here we are the
sea snake has taken a grave wound in
back in Step stance
you are left four years ago even senile
and decaying viserys would be excellent
at TV since
and apparently a grandson slash nephew
that your daughter is a mother cousin
too
you do
but what I worry about starting the next
sentence after saying I believe you with
the word but have you seen Diana she
supposed to dress the children
convenient affected third party barge in
is convenient I'd be surprised if he
could remember his own name to be fair
there's only about three names to go
around in your family so I bet he gets
there pretty fast smaller than I
remember it looks exactly the same
conversation in every one of my sex
tapes wait is the Valerian Banner a
seahorse and Corliss goes by the name
sea snake is everything and everyone in
this house a c word wait
learning crashes a new mother cries The
Song of Ice and Fire do you believe it
to be true the first few volumes sure
but I'm pretty sure the rest is a myth
also this is good at times I need to
send this show for not even touching on
the more magical aspects that the OG
Game of Thrones did so well that show
literally started with an army of Frozen
dead people and this Show's like we've
got dragons and that's all you're
getting
[Music]
of all the things I was hoping this show
would take the time to flesh out a bit
more viserys's back sores were top of
that list hoorah the Lord of church mark
lord of the tides in brings are you the
Lord of those two I only ask because I
might all of a sudden get interested in
the show again kingless Aries of House
Targaryen now we're talking finally some
energy in this episode vaser is showing
up to put people in their place is
awesome about the fact that it took 40
minutes to get here in the most decrepit
character in the series to make it
happen still deserves this sin those who
have seen your face draw back and Fear
The
Phantom of the harbors
here inside
today ah yes fine take the sin off the
scene rules but also the king's hitting
the throne that is essentially
responsible for his current conditions
seems a little ironic or at least
balanis Morissette's version of ironic I
do not understand
petitions are being heard over a settled
succession well it's this thing called
dramatic tension and the show needed
something to occupy itself with instead
of fleshing out the backstories and
character development of the other main
characters while they stall and get to
the final two episodes that help my
house survived the Doom he's got a good
point that's nothing to sneeze at that
was a really tough game The Inferno
episode was especially tough but still
bragging will always get you a sin so I
will not see it ended on the account of
this
head
Matt Smith coming through in the clutch
again almost saving this episode one
more sent off for the final bits of this
thing but that's all you're getting the
silent sisters are attempting to put
vaman back together again instead of
just embracing his new role as a
marionette I think the thing that
surprises me most about this scene is
it's only the eighth strangest thing
I've seen on television this week to be
fair I did just catch up on season 8 of
The Masked Singer though also I love
that even in a scenario where the body
on the table has his chin separated from
the rest of his head they still bother
to place a towel over the private parts
this over candling wall behind rhaenis
is the most over-candled wall to ever
over candle might as well be a Christmas
display on one of those houses the
people with too much time on their hands
own this is an occasion celebration it
seems he says just a few hours after
person had his head bisected before him
as he sat on the throne
a future lord of the tides I'm actually
really glad this all worked out this way
Prince luceres is sure to grow into a
noble King and since we spent so much
time with him on this episode you know
his reign will be food for the story for
years to come good thing he's not going
anywhere did you know
how the ACT is done I assume getting
one-upped by the kid who married his
sister
[Applause]
exposing your eye rectum at the family
dinner I wish to raise my cup to her
grace the queen awkward dinner toasts
which is also what most people would
call every single dinner toast also I do
like what the show is doing here the
idea that viserys could make one final
push for Unity and it would find
purchase in the hearts enough to mend
moats is a beautiful idea and completely
insane these two cross the line of no
return on their relationship a long time
ago and no amount of One-Eyed
speechifying is ever going to change it
we have now reached the portion of the
episode where people stand up and then
other people look at the people standing
up and then stay standing up for several
seconds as the cameras beg us to feel
tension the only thing I'm wondering is
I would like to toast Baylor and Rayna
oh come on at this point I'd rather be
watching someone make actual toasts than
sit through another one of these things
I know we've been through a few time
jumps but did eamon's time jumps have a
plus 10 modifier on them why does this
child look 31. Harlem
return on Dragon back get it it seems
like she means in a friendly way but
then it probably won't be get it do you
get it oh good we're bringing her back
you know her I totally know who she is I
just want to make sure you know who she
is there are too many damn characters to
keep up with on this show don't you
remember
Akon Alison Prince that was promised
princess
I understand my king and this is why you
don't name all your kids George Foreman
giving me the stink eye the mouth
mouthful
who goes there I am Archer at Emissary
of the gorgonites
oh there's just like the faintest Sousa
of like uh asparagus and there's a just
a flutter of like a like a Nutty Edom
cheese I don't give a [ __ ] about 20s
wait to my phone
I'll make you a
minute off I'm gonna make a monograph
ERS Brothers don't shake hands Brothers
gotta hug
oh my God
[Music]
sometimes you think you have true love
and then you catch the early flight home
from San Diego and a couple of new
people jump out of your bathroom
blindfolded like a goddamn magic show
ready to double team your girlfriend